Tom Hanks is known as the nicest guy in
Hollywood but his new novel is about an
actor who's kind of a nightmare
surprisingly Hank says a character is
based at least partially on himself
that's right even America's dad has bad
days apparently according to Hank's new
interview with the BBC he doesn't always
succeed at being the nicest guy in the
room while promoting his first novel The
Making of another major Motion Picture
Masterpiece Hank said that the Arrogant
actor in the story is partially inspired
by some of his most stressful days on
set revealing I have pulled every single
one of those moments of behavior myself
on a set not everybody is at their best
every single day on a motion picture set
I've had tough days trying to be a
professional when my life has been
falling apart in more ways than one and
a requirement for me that day is to be
funny charming and loving and it's the
last way I feel the book focuses on the
drama behind the scenes of a wildly
expensive superhero film from a
megalomaniac director to the
aforementioned difficult actor the actor
constantly keeps causing delays to the
filming with his bad behavior yeah
obviously this is an exaggerated version
of hangouts's real unset Behavior but in
any case he's admitting that he isn't
always perfect that rug was given to me
by the Dalai Lama
and you sent it in for cleaning you're
out the picture the Academy Award winner
did say there's one rule he never breaks
about onset Behavior unlike the
fictional actor in his book who
struggles with punctuality and causes
problems when he eventually arrives on
set Hanks makes sure he's never tardy
for a shoot he said what's cannot occur
on a motion picture is that someone can
a monkey around with the timing or the
length of the shoot or the budget that
is a cardinal sin and the motion picture
business you will be amazed at how many
people know that they can get away with
her and they're told they can get away
with it because they are carrying the
movie on their shoulders it's not
surprising that someone as established
as Hanks who has been a major part of
the film and TV industry for decades has
some internalized rules he'll never
break he's only human though and
sometimes his demeanor slips it's
sometimes for good reason though for
example when some fans are chasing Hanks
and his wife Rita Wilson in the summer
of 2022 one trip to Wilson Hanks was
enraged jumping to the defense of his
wife and shouting back the off even
with the occasional bad day for Hanks it
doesn't seem to have translated to him
losing work he's one of Hollywood's most
prominent and consistently cast actors
notably he went two Oscars in a row for
Forrest Gump and Philadelphia and he
hasn't slowed down since working with
directors like Steven Spielberg and Ron
Howard regularly regarded as one of the
best living actors Hans is also one of
the highest grossing performers working
today so obviously directors are willing
to overlook a few bad moments here and
there in 2022 alone he appeared in three
high-profile projects bars lerman's
biopic Elvis His frequent collaborator
Robert zemeckis's adaptation of
Pinocchio and the heartwarming family
flick a man called Otto do you think I'm
going to cut myself and bleed all over
your floor and sue you he's also dabbled
in television documentaries in the last
several years producing 2019's the
movies and 1968 the year that changed
America he also worked with Yellowstone
head honcho Taylor Sheridan on an
episode of the spin-off 1883. Hanks
isn't going anywhere anytime soon and if
you want to check out the dramatized
version of his unset Behavior the making
of another major Motion Picture
Masterpiece is out now
foreign